At this point in the process you might
be thinking, all right I'm ready to go.
Let's do this.
But there might be a small voice
in the back of your head or perhaps
a very loud one that's saying, wait.
I'm not a graphic designer.
I'm not an artist.
How am I going to make this app actually
look good so people want to use it?
To which I say, don't worry.
There's a lot of great services out
there that provide high quality
images and graphics that you
can use in your own app.
First, you have your basic
Google image search.
Now anything that you search here
will bring up a lot of results.
So you'll need to be wary of
any copyright restrictions.
But, given the right search terms,
you can find some real and free gems.
iStock photo and 99 Designs are also
great options if you're looking for
more professional high quality graphics.
However, these services
do cost a bit of money,
but they're usually pretty reasonable.
Maybe there are other services out there
that you've found that you are going to
use in your app.
If you find those,
I encourage you to share them with
your fellow classmates on the forum.
I'll actually be interested to see them,
too.